yeah yeah
she's my best friend we spend as much
time as we can together
she is the goat she's an amazing model
Mother after 13 years of marriage and
more than 100 red carpets Tom and Gisele
filed for divorce this morning a source
tells E.T Giselle and Tom worked on the
terms of their settlement with a
mediator we've also learned they agreed
to join custody of their children the
couple broke the news on Instagram Tom
called the decision painful and
difficult Giselle said we have grown
apart I feel blessed for the time we had
together and only wish the best for Tom
always so what caused the split I feel
like I'm so driven to succeed in
football for Giselle we're told it was
family versus football this morning our
source said after years of sacrifice and
basically being a single parent while
Tom was playing football Giselle had
enough despite that a source close to
the couple calls Tom a devoted father
adding he is always with his family in
between games and traveling but this
couldn't have helped I've never quit on
anything in my life on his podcast this
week Tom doubled down on his commitment
to the Buccaneers there's no immediate
retirement in my future there was a
retirement in the past but I moved on
from that
one big question what will happen to the
dream home the couple had been building
on this exclusive Island in Miami the
Mansion is said to be worth 30 million
dollars construction was recently halted
due to the damage caused by Hurricane
Ian as for how everyone is holding up
the 42 year old has been working with
her spiritual healer to stay in a place
of Peace but there's no peace at the
moment for Tom you know I think we
struggle pretty much at everything last
night he suffered his first straight
three-game loss in the last 20 years the
45 year old also became the most sacked
quarterback in NFL history but to be
fair Tom's been playing for more than
two decades and has won seven Super
Bowls we're playing the win so you know
losing is no fun for any of us